yeah that was pretty good right like I'm
high right it's really hot yeah I don't
know how you do it man maybe just I have
oh all right
here we go too much hair product in my
hair okay good morning believe nations
my name is Alexson my one word is belong
and I believe the world would be a
better place if more people felt that
they belong so to help you on your
journey
today's messages be a blessing to
somebody over to you Maya Angelou
[Music]
there's an African Americans on 19th
century the chin is so great it says
when it looked like the Sun won or shine
anymore God put a rainbow in the clouds
imagine and I've had so many rainbows in
my clouds I had a lot of clouds but I
have had so many rainbows and one of the
things I do when I step up on a stage
when I stand up to translate when I go
to teach my classes when I go to direct
a movie I bring everyone who has ever
been kind to me with me black white
asian spanish-speaking Native American
gay straight everybody has to come with
me I'm going a mistake come with me I
need you now long did you see so I don't
ever feel I have no help I've had
rainbows in my clouds and the thing to
do it seems to me is to prepare yourself
so that you can be a rainbow in somebody
else's cloud somebody who may not look
like you may not call God the same name
you call God if they call God it off you
see and may not eat the same dishes
prepared the way you do may not dance
your dances well speak your language
but be a blessing to somebody this
message resonates with me as a human
being as an instructor as a speaker as a
leader it is super important that you
take responsibility not only for
yourself but for the well-being of
others because ultimately you never know
what kind of impact you can have on
others when I was a student seven years
ago
I struggled asking women to dance so
here was I sort of a beginner dancer
going to socials and just being too
afraid to mess up make mistakes and
people not wanting to dance with me and
I remember there was a short woman she
was like five foot one five foot she
came up to me she was an advanced dancer
she had no reason really to ask me to
dance but she saw how afraid I was and
she offered to dance with me and for
multiple socials as I kept going out she
would always ask me to that and every
time I gets nervous
I'd make mistakes I'd be hard on myself
I said looking around and looking at all
these other people dancing and just that
being intimidating for me she would tell
me that it's okay that it's not
important just keep dancing smiling that
I'll get better
I saw her about six years later out of
social by this point I was already an
instructor when I saw her I one of our
soldiers I ran up and I gave her a hug
and I told her how much of a difference
in in fact she made on me on my
confidence and was one of the pivotal
reasons why I stuck around even though
at the beginning I was one of the worst
dancer never underestimate how powerful
a simple hello a thank you are you doing
a great job can be every single day is
an opportunity to make a positive impact
in the smallest of gestures in people's
lives
and all can sometimes take is just a one
second of you stopping and doing what
you feel is right versus walking away
and not wanting to deal with the hassle
thing take responsibility not only for
yourself but take responsibility for
others and be a rainbow and somebody's
cloud the question of the day is what's
one regret that you have right now where
you wish you could have been a rainbow
in someone else's clouds but you didn't
take action leave it in the comments
below I'm excited to see what you have
to say I want to get
quick shout out to Emma Heyward Emma
thank you so much for purchasing Evans
book it really means a lot to us I'm
really curious when you figure out your
one word and when you do leave it in the
comments below with your answer thank
you so much for watching we believe in
you and we hope you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever your one word
is and we'll see you tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso
[Music]
salsa says affection written answer if
you do wrong things mainly harming other
you get negative consequences if you do
have another bring more happiness to
other will get none of it more
intersting there and more sort of
confidence of purpose of life and
fulfillment about that purpose then you
already said happy I get the advantage
that that my generation has when we were
in film school we're starting the film
business the door was absolutely locked
and it was a very very high wall and
nobody got in there for all of us
beggars and scroungers down at the front
gate decided that if if we didn't sort
of band together we wouldn't survive and
that if one could make it that one would
help all the others make it and we would
continue to help each other
so we've banded together I mean that's
how Cavin figured it out any society
starts that way any society begins by
realizing it together by helping each
other you can survive better than if you
fight each other and compete with each
other if I got a job I would help
somebody else get a job if somebody got
more successful than me it was partly my
success I wasn't my success wasn't based
on how I could push down everybody that
was around me my success was based on
how much I could push everybody up and
eventually their success was the same
way and in the process they pushed me up
and I pushed them up and we kept doing
that and we still do that and even
though we all have in essence competing
companies we see it as if everybody
succeeds my friend succeeds that
everybody succeeds so that that and
that's the key to it is to have
everybody succeed not to gloat over
somebody else's failure one of the basic
motifs of fairytales is that you find
the poor unfortunate along the side of
the road and when they beg for help if
you give it to them you end up
succeeding if you don't give it to them
you end up being turned into a frog or
something so it's something that's been
around for thousands of years a concept
that's been around for thousands of
years
and it is even more necessary today when
people are much more into their own in
grand iseman than they are in helping
other people I mean the one thing about
you here at the Academy here is
constantly about public service about
helping others I only have anybody who's
become successful that doesn't
understand how important it is to be
part of the larger community to help
other people in larger community to give
back to the community and it's not
something you do you start doing when
you've made it now I'm on the top I can
sort of enhance my joy and self-esteem
by helping the poor underlings it's when
you are at the very lowest level and
you're struggling when we were in film
school we were all very very poor we
were all very very struggling they all
need jobs very desperately and if one of
us couldn't get a particular job we'd
send another friend in on the interview
because we were hoping that one of us
would get the job and so you'd do it
right from the very beginning you can
start every single day you know whether
it's helping your brother or sister or
helping your peers at school or helping
in the community but it's not just it's
not just a kind of public service thing
it's a way of life if America is the
pursuit of happiness the best way to
pursue happiness is to help other people
because there's nothing else that will
make you happy you can be as rich and
famous and powerful you want to be and
it will not bring you happiness and I've
said over and over and over again in
such a cliche that it hardly goes it
harder needs to be said but people don't
understand that it's actually true and
you can find people rich powerful and
famous and they aren't happy and you can
find people who've discovered the fact
that it's really helping people it's
really being compassionate where other
human beings that makes you happy at the
risk of sounding like a Miss America
contestant the most fulfilling things
I've experienced who truly been the
human interactions
spending time with women and village
banks in Mexico with sink microfinance
organization meeting young women who
were the first and only in their
communities to attend secondary school
in rural Kenya with free the children of
groups that build sustainable schools in
developing countries trekking with
gorillas conservationists in Rwanda it's
a cliche because it's true that helping
others ends up helping you more than
anyone getting out of your own concern
and caring about someone else's life for
a while reminds you that you are not the
center of the universe and that in the
ways we are generous or not we can
change the course of someone's life even
at work the small seeds of kindness crew
members directors fellow actors have
shown me have had the most lasting
impact